you're watching the daily climate show
on sky
news on today's programme a warning that
the uk
isn't prepared for extreme heat waves
which could become more frequent
due to climate change we hear about the
sand storms and severe wind battering
those living in displacement camps
in yemen and how low carbon concrete
could be the key to building a greener
[Music]
future
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions now think of heatwaves and you
might picture cool drinks in the shade
or a family barbecue
in the sun but the red cross is warning
there's a dangerous perception gap in
the uk when it comes to the public's
awareness of the risks
of extreme heat now the charity says the
impact of climate change
could mean heat-related deaths in the uk
triple in the next 30 years
around 7 000 each year but
25 percent of people don't think the uk
is hot enough
to be at risk from heat waves now that's
despite a record
2566 excess deaths
in england alone last summer from the
heat
the warning follows a recent report from
the climate change committee that
criticized the government for allowing
more than half a million
new homes to be built without features
to cope with higher temperatures
well a study published today in the
journal nature suggests extreme heat
events which break weather records by
large margins
will become more likely as a result of
climate change
so let's bring in dr helen hanlon senior
scientist at the met office
uh welcome to you first of all do you
agree that people in the uk are a little
naive
about the dangers of heat waves and
extreme heat
well currently we don't see we don't see
temperatures that often reaching to the
sorts of levels where you'll start to
see health impacts
these are projected to increase
dramatically with global warming though
um i have just done a study where i've
projected with the latest set of met
office climate projections
that if we reach two degrees of global
warming we could see a doubling
of the number of days where we will see
hot hot days
high enough to increase our risk due to
our health our health risk
but also um by four degrees if we
reached four degrees of global warming
this could be a four-fold increase so
yes this would be definitely
increasing um the frequency by which we
have um
days that pose a risk to our health from
extreme heat
and what is class as a heat wave here
so here um i have taken a hot day to be
a day where the temperatures exceed 25
degrees
and that means that the the daytime
temperatures exceed that could be up to
up to mid 30s by 2050s we are starting
to see in our climate projections
temperatures
exceeding 40 our current record
temperature in the uk
is 38.7 so this would be a considerable
increase in what we are used to
and would need absorb we would need to
adapt to
and clearly there's a battle on to try
to control the rise in temperatures but
if there are more heat waves on the
horizon what can be done to adapt to
them
so it's the things that you need to do
to sort of avoid um
heat exhaustion and things like staying
hydrated so if you're going out
take a bottle of water with you it's the
same as if you had a weather forecast
saying it was going to rain you take
your umbrella but in this case if it
says
extreme heat then you need to remember
to take your your water bottle with you
but there's
there's other things um to be concerned
about such as the most of our buildings
in the uk
are not built to withstand um high
temperatures
and keep us cool in those high
temperatures um so there is a
significant need for um changes to
building standards and also adapting
the homes that we currently have dr
helen helen thanks very much indeed
thank you very much let's take a look
now at some of the day's other climate
news and a town in worcestershire will
get
6.2 million pounds for a permanent flood
defense
after being washed out three years in a
row bewdley will have its temporary
barriers replaced to help protect homes
and businesses from future floods
a further 4.5 million pounds will be
invested in smaller projects within the
seven valley
to manage flooding in the long term
british vault says the construction of
its huge electric car
battery gigafactory in the uk is not far
away
a shovel in the ground ceremony took
place this morning on the site in
northumberland
where blythe power station used to be
it's hoped the gigafactory will produce
enough
lithium-ion batteries for 000 electric
cars a year
by 2027. and tourists and cornwall are
being encouraged to use their
phones to donate to local environmental
projects
qr codes have started appearing in
beauty spots across the region
as part of the love where you are
campaign people can scan the codes on
their phones to open up donation pages
for organizations that are working to
protect the environment and help
cornwall become
carbon neutral now we've talked a lot
recently about
extreme weather events such as floods
and wildfires but for many countries
sandstorms can also pose a lethal threat
in yemen harsh living conditions for
those in refugee camps
have been made even worse by the storms
which scientists say
could become more common and intense
because of climate change
well let's bring in abdul wasiya
muhammad who's oxfam's policy lead in
yemen
welcome to you tell us a little bit
about how bad these storms have been
lately and what it's like for people
living in those conditions
yeah thank you very much thank you for
having me and thank you for highlighting
the climate
issues in yemen just to start with the
the
climate change in yemen has not been an
issue that is being talked about a lot
due to the multiple crisis yemen has
already due to the conflict
which has started in 2015 this has
the the climate change issues have been
noticed in the past few
years especially across the the country
there have been devastating
impacts especially on vulnerable groups
like
the idp communities in across the
country
and in maribor i have been recently i
have seen devastating
impacts on idps where
they live already harsh conditions and
these
sandstones and dust stones have made it
worse for them
to to survive in their fragile
tents and and make shifts actually
one week into my arrival in yemen uh
there was a
an infant that has died due to the
collapse of a tent
uh due to these strong winds in in in
america
uh people in europe have been struggling
a lot
and so are across the country
about the strong winds and the
sandstorms and
all this dust have uh further worsened
their struggle well yes and how
concerned are you for the future and the
impact that
climate change could have in the years
ahead it's not just sandstorms is it
there is the risk of more floods and
droughts too
it is alarming especially uh because
people are already struggling with
accessing basic
services including health and water and
sanitation services
uh there are over one million idps
in in america in particular who are
struggling a
day on day-to-day basis to survive
and the strong winds the dust storms and
also the sandstorms have made it
have made their lives even worse
abdulbasia mohammed thanks very much
indeed
thank you now a new innovation could
mean
future emissions from the construction
industry don't have to be set in
precast concrete a uk team has developed
a process to reduce carbon emissions
from the building material
by up to 40 percent now we'll find out
more
about how they did it in a moment but
first here's why we need
the solution
[Music]
so
[Applause]
well joining me now is susan bernal
professor of structural materials at the
university of leeds welcome to you
first of all just how great is the
environmental impact of concrete
well thank you for having me this
evening and
it is vast and this is mainly due to the
high amount of concrete
that is needed to fulfill the demand for
infrastructure and buildings to
enable our cities to grow and develop
so what do you make of this new process
which could mean
that 40 percent fewer carbon emissions
are
emitted could this be the future
well i think this is an excellent
example that we can do more with
less by applying fundamental concepts
during the material selection
a process and by optimizing design which
can have a significant
impact in sustainability of structures
in my opinion the proposed approach is
really clever because it can be rapidly
implemented doesn't cause major changes
from current construction practices
that can enable us to achieve major
environmental savings in the years to
come
well yes so how optimistic are you for
the future that we can
find green alternatives to traditional
concrete
well this is my area of research so i
feel very optimistic about it
but over the past few years major cement
and concrete producers
in the uk and elsewhere have actively
worked
in the development and commercialization
of green alternatives
that are starting to become available in
the market
and i will say practitioners are also
becoming more aware
that we need to shift from using a
single material for every application
and instead we need to make use of any
potential option available
considering sustainability credentials
and are there cost implications of going
greener
in some instances there might be but in
the longer term
and with potential increase in carbon
taxes
and also extending longevity of these
sustainable materials
i think it could be a cost benefit
professor susan bernal thanks very much
indeed
thank you well that's everything from us
for today
next time bringing climate stories to
life through photography
you can find out more here tomorrow on
the daily climate show see you then
you